135
150 lakers led by as many as 38 never
trailed that's three in a row isn't it i
did think it was going to at least
thank you kitty make you feel a lot
better
well i will say this this was a total
domination by the lakers i think total
domination
but i would have taken my hat off to the
polling trailblazers
they did not quit they did they had no
keep talking
hold on they had no chance of winning
that game in the second half and they
competed
but uh obviously i was wrong say it
again
i was wrong here's and here's what he
was wrong about as we
roll the highlights of game four between
the lakers
and the blazers uh on mamba day
um this was ugly this got
off to a 15 nothing start
the lakers knew that we got to put this
team away don't give them a chance they
came out smoking
a d from the mid-range kcp
nice he he ca he was the difference
and look at that score huh on mama day
24 to 8.
see i don't mind that kidding from him
because that's his game
[Music]
give me that trailblazers got frustrated
by the officials
yeah they're really good you saw that
chased down by lebron and
lebron again oh jelly
what's the jelly honey jelly
[Music]
here he goes again rolly ball 22 in the
first half on eight out of nine shooting
pulling up they were up 80 to 51 at the
half
man look at that say hey to steph and
dean when you're out there
wow 135 to 115.
uh 135 the most
playoff points in a game for the lakers
since 1987. wow
led by as many as 38 they lead the
series 3-1 here's terry stotts
uh only that obviously you heard his
knee and uh
i believe he's getting an mri
the next question is coming from casey
old trailblazers.com
i'll come back to casey next question's
coming from jason here
coaches how would you describe the
position you guys are in right now
uh not good you know it's uh
you're down one three uh you know it's a
tough position against a good team
so um you know we're regroup
it's one game at a time you can break
out all the cliches but uh
we know what we're up against when
you're down to a good team 3-1
so we got a battle
all right casey go ahead
harry how would you uh how would you
describe the the start you guys had
tonight
um obviously pretty
fifty-nil so how would you describe this
how you guys came out
uh you know obviously they uh lakers
were clicking on all cylinders
uh and you know offense couldn't get
anything going early so
um you know they they played really well
and we
we got off to a poor start and uh
obviously it put us
all in a hole a big hole to begin with
so
we were fighting uphill all night